oh my goodness I have seen the light
people of the internet My Hope for this
game just went through the roof there
are so many insane story details
gameplay details and just epic moments
in general that I have no doubt fans are
going to have plenty to talk about from
now all the way up to the game's launch
on May 12th and so for this video I'd
like to focus specifically on 10 details
I noticed that will have a direct impact
on gameplay and tears at the Kingdom
starting with the Chica slate because it
actually looks like it's coming back
however it seems like it's going to be
in a different capacity than what fans
will remember from breath of the wild if
you missed it you can spot it during the
scene when link is riding the elevator
up you know the one where it sounds like
they're saying the future
seriously cannot unhear this now
up until this point we hadn't seen link
using the Chica slate and any of the
trailers despite the fact that it played
such an important role in the first game
it's how you access the map which then
enabled you to place markers and
waypoints you could use it as a scope to
zoom in on things in the world and of
course tell link was able to use all of
the roon abilities he had access to in
breath of the wild such as magnesis and
the others in the previous gameplay
demonstration for tears of the Kingdom
we saw four new abilities but none of
them were controlled with anything like
ashika slate instead they were all
controlled by Link's modified right arm
is it a zonai arm is that mysterious
green force powering it who knows but as
for the Chica slate it appears to be
Tethered to the elevator and the winch
that you can see here and since we don't
see it anywhere else should we presume
that we'll only have access to the Slate
when its nd's elevators or maybe we only
have access to the Slate during certain
portions of the game maybe we'd lose it
and have to find it again still so many
questions but we now know it is back at
least in some form and speaking of
coming back I think that this latest
trailer shows there's a really good
dungeons are making a return in tears of
the Kingdom alright so let's call
attention to a few moments in the
trailer first this one in the desert
where we see this massive structure
rising up from the sand now I believe
this area we're looking at is just to
the east of the Arbiters grounds that we
know from breath of the wild and to me
this just seems way too big for
something like a shrine I mean for a
sense of scale here look at the size of
it compared to that little green swirl
building that we've seen in the other
trailers we thought those had the
potential to be shrines and this is just
enormous in comparison all right all
right I know not convinced yet that's
not all just a bit later in the trailer
we have two more scenes that I think are
highly likely to be inside Death
Mountain and of course as long time fans
will know Death Mountain has been used
plenty of times before as a location for
a dungeon throughout the history of
Zelda games so right here we can see
link wearing the flame breaker armor set
we've got lava falling down on either
side what looks like a bridge over here
and then some platforms over here where
it looks as if we can make our way even
further into the mountain and then just
a bit later I think we get one more shot
actually inside and this is the one
where link is riding the mining cart
doing battle against the construct enemy
here still wearing flamebreaker armor we
can still see the lava the whole area
looks very much like we are in the
mining section of Death Mountain you
could even see a Goron symbol on the
cart here I think we're pretty spot on
with the location the biggest question
that remains is whether or not it's a
true dungeon like what we've seen in
previous Zelda games maybe it's wishful
thinking on my part but I personally
think this area looks vast enough and
significant enough we can see so many
different little sections here to where
I think we can say this has a decent
shot what do you think 50 50 of being a
traditional Zelda dungeon which is
certainly more than we had seen up to
this point when it comes to this game
now speaking of those carts though
Nintendo showed off quite a few more
examples in this trailer of Link's new
abilities and how they'll affect
gameplay remember those powered fans
from the gameplay demonstration well you
can see them here in that very same
mining area each cart has one on the
back and we can presume I think that
this will require battery power just
like the others it's important to
remember Nintendo usually disables all
all HUD elements in the trailer so
that's probably why we're not seeing
them here now a bit later in the trailer
we see a different type of cart not a
mining cart but a cart that's being
drawn by a horse with link riding this
one is super interesting because it
looks as if we'll need to find all four
of these wheels for the cart you can see
the green glue magic Force Zone eye
energy do we have a name for this stuff
yet anybody there's an additional Ultra
hand Point here enabling link and his
horse to actually pull the card along
and transport the people here how cool
is that maybe this is a side mission or
even a main mission because it certainly
seems like NPCs and all the towns people
are going to be playing a much bigger
role this time and that leads perfectly
into our next gameplay detail because
these townspeople it seems like they and
the other NPCs are going to be playing a
much more important role in this game we
can see them here as link is riding in
they're fighting back they're using
whatever they have to defend themselves
they're organizing working together and
just generally trying to defend their
territory you can see over here where
they've attempted to fortify the walls
with this wood and these spikes I'm sure
there's a technical name that somebody
in the comments will correct me on
there's also a separate shot later in
the trailer that shows a group with just
regular townsfolk in addition to a Goron
a Gerudo and this person who definitely
looks like they could hold their own in
battle oh and we can't forget Bucket Man
here future king of Hyrule right here
but a big focus of this trailer overall
is that it really seems to highlight
everyone coming together to try and save
Hyrule it's not just the townspeople
though we do see other moments with fan
favorite characters like sidon here
actually fighting alongside Us in battle
of course we had the champions in breath
of the wild but this trailer really
seemed to highlight gameplay sections
featuring companions with them fighting
directly alongside us and you can see he
is impacting this battle here there's
even a voice in the trailer actually not
sure who it is that's saying this
definitely not the same voice as Zelda
but they say but You are not alone and I
really like this I think it's going to
be interesting to see how much they
actually lean into this in the final
game of course you already know link is
the hero it's pretty much going to come
down to him and Zelda but I love seeing
more characters step up and hopefully
play a key role in the story and oh man
the story so many things I want to say
stay tuned for a future video gotta stay
focused here on the gameplay fuse oh man
we gotta talk about fuse we highlighted
Ultra hand already and some additional
uses for it earlier in the video but it
looks like fuse is going to be just as
important let's be honest we all knew
from the moment they showed this ability
there were going to be a ridiculous
number of insane Creations unexpected
combinations that people would be able
to create so Nintendo they're like okay
we'll show you just a few more of them
here in this trailer starting with the
fact that apparently you confuse a
shield to a sword I believe we have a
royal Claymore here fused with a royal
shield and this time we could see link
taking on two of the construct enemies
on what appears to be a sky island and
not only does he use this fused creation
to deflect the attack you can see it
actually breaks the the sword of the
construct enemy I've watched this
trailer so many times guys this is one
of those that I didn't even catch until
the very last moment editing this video
I was watching frame by frame and when
he's going in for the strike here you
can clearly see this stone sword but
then after the strike you get the flash
there and then when he pulls back look
no more sword so the question here what
is the benefit of this fused sword and
shield how is it different from just
holding the shield in your left hand
does it make the enemy's weapon more
likely to break as we see here we
already know that the fuse weapons on
Link's side will get both stronger and
more durable and they did show us the
Puffs room in the gameplay demo that was
fused to the shield but I never even
considered the possibility of a shield
fusing to a sword like what happens
after this moment right here this link
just bash him over the head with the
shield sword shield sword that wasn't
all for fuse though we also saw link
fusing his shield to a rocket that's
right a rocket in a Zelda game and in
this instance he's using it as a
traversal mechanic on what I'm pretty
sure is Eventide Island Again powered by
that green energy oh and we get to see
fire arrows in this one as well link
uses a ruby I think to form one right
here I guess it could also be a bomb
Arrow but definitely looks more like a
regular fire arrow to me and I do think
this also confirms one of my suspicions
after watching that first gameplay demo
if you remember when they showed the
white shoe jelly forming the ice Arrow
they did not say that that is the only
item that can create an ice Arrow they
actually just said if you fuse an ice
Elemental material to an arrow so I
think you'll probably be able to use the
red chew jelly to form fire arrows in
addition to the rubies maybe the rarer
the item the stronger the arrow again
just so many possibilities here oh the
possibilities you guys because
apparently link can build his own
freaking Mech now we had already seen
that stone Talos with the bokoblin enemy
camp traveling along for the ride but
thanks to ultra hand it looks like link
will have the ability to make his very
own portable Siege Tower to combat them
okay there's so much going on in this
incredibly brief shot here so many
questions are these random Stone pieces
found throughout the world or was this a
column from something else that he just
glued on the pans here actually wait
this looks more like some sort of arm
cannon on the right then you have these
wheels on the bottom much bigger than
the wheels that were used before on that
horse-drawn cart on top you also have
link using the steering mechanism so it
will actually be piloting this thing
ourselves and then on the left side here
I can't tell if that's just the other
piece of stone I'm seeing or if there's
actually another glued item on the left
side maybe another Cannon actually I
think it's just the other piece of stone
but who knows could be a cannon over
there too I just keep thinking about all
these creations we've seen so far and
now considering this I mean can we glue
these cannons to any vehicle can we have
a flying vehicle with just like multiple
cannons fused to the side or wait it's
Ultra hand now right I'm gonna get those
two confused so much all right so far we
focused on abilities that were already
announced and this trailer just showed
us new uses for them but now let's take
a look at a few gameplay details that
are completely new in this trailer
starting with these zero gravity jumps
now my guess here is that this is some
sort of timed effect that link activates
through the environment maybe from a
post I do think it's something that he
activates on his way up here maybe he
passes through some sort of force field
or activates a power up you know it
could even be tied to the platform
itself if you look at the coloration
here yep you see it right more of the
green stuff and they look as if they're
sort of pulsing on and off they'll glow
green for a moment and then turn gray
then green again if you look at just
link though I'm not seeing any
indication that he has used some sort of
power so I don't think it's an ability
tied to the arm like fuse and Ultra hand
definitely seems to be more of an
environmental thing that we activate
Okay hold on wait wait wait in that same
shot look over here to the left you can
see these floating bubbles with that
green center pretty sure these are the
very same bubbles that link jumps into
just a bit earlier in the trailer we can
see they sort of emerge from this
platform then link jumps inside and he's
sort of just floating swimming maybe
definitely looks like water here all
right I'm forming a theory here my guess
is that we have a limited amount of time
after being inside these bubbles that
this zero gravity effect will hold so
jump in the bubble then they transport
you then you have to jump out and then I
don't know for 10 15 seconds you have
this sort of zero gravity jump effect so
on the opposite side of zero gravity we
also have to talk about Link's new
wingsuit paragliding sure yeah it's in
the game it's going to be fun but a full
on wingsuit this is going to be
incredible it's a very quick section of
the trailer we only see it for a brief
moment but link is using this suit here
to fall through the tunnel notice you'll
see him use it here to actually slow
down and avoid the red lasers which now
that I'm looking at this again is this
going down into Death Mountain is this
actually how we get inside the mountain
you know maybe he do from a sky island
that was just overhead I'm just hoping
this isn't like a one-time scripted
thing hopefully there are plenty of uses
for the wingsuit in the game you know
it's such a huge focus in all the
trailers on these sky islands and all
the new traversal mechanics to get to
and from them hopefully it's a safe bet
to say that the wingsuit is gonna get
put to very good use in tears of the
kingdom and finally we have to talk
about the elephant in the room because
there are some apps absolutely massive
massive enemies in this game are they
just World bosses dungeon bosses all of
the above because we gotta look at so
many epics just huge enemies in this
game there's this ice tarantula
centipede thing a brand new construct
enemy that's enormous in size compared
to the others that we've seen so far and
then of course the three-headed fire
dragon that has to be the return of glia
which we saw briefly in a previous
trailer but from much further away now
he's up close and personal and just look
at the size of this thing I can't wait
to see how we're gonna take him down and
yeah the big bad himself Ganondorf you
knew I couldn't end it without talking
about him right he's back and this model
looks absolutely incredible maybe he's
not as massive as the other enemies at
least in physical size but he is
absolutely just as imposing I love this
version of Ganondorf you guys there were
so many epic moments in this trailer in
fact I think in my next video I'm just
gonna have to solely focus on epic
moments in this trailer I'll link it
here on the right side of the screen
when it's ready what was your favorite
part of the new trailer let me know the
comments guys as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon